welcome back everyone this is
lecture 20 of cs229 and the main topic
for today will be variational auto
encoders so variational auto encoders is
probably one of the
simplest
deep generative models uh so deep
generative models is a very hot topic in
machine learning right now where we try
to build generative models of our data
using neural networks and variational
auto encoders was one of the uh one of
the early early
models which made good progress in this
field and is also probably the model
that you know one should uh start
studying first because it has the key
components that are kind of necessary
that are used in in more fancier models
so uh for all for for studying
variational auto encoders
first we will look at you know simple
auto encoders uh
auto encoders have a long history and
um
we will look at you know
what simple auto encoders are and then
we'll kind of
switch gears back into expectation
maximization and look at a very look at
a few variants of expectation
maximization because that that ah kind
of
gives good motivation into uh
variational auto encoders we'll first
study something called as mcmc
expectation maximizer mcm cem where mcmc
stands for
markov chain monte carlo
and
we will also
we will also have a quick look at
variational inference which is kind of
like a counterpart to monte carlo
techniques
and then we will look at yet another
variant of em called variation em and
then switch gears into the variation
auto encoder itself so that's the
plan for today and
so if if if in terms of the overall
course if you are able to cover this
today then probably today will be kind
of uh the last
math intensive class we'll have one more
class on on friday we'll where we'll be
covering more um general topics like um
like um um evaluation metrics and and
you know general tips for uh executing
machine learning projects that will not
be as math heavy so probably this is
going to be the last math heavy class
and next week we'll be just doing review
of all the uh
topics that we have done in the course
and also the review that we do next week
will
you know kind of uh will be suggestive
of the kind of topics that are important
for your final exam so we'll be
stressing more on topics that are um
important for the final exam so that you
can focus on them yes questions
so the final is cumulative uh it is it
is uh since we did not have a midterm
it's you know it's cumulative it covers
everything yeah
uh so a quick recap of what we covered
in the last class so in the last class
we mostly dealt with the principle
called the maximum entropy principle
where entropy of a probability
distribution is defined as the exp the
expectation of the negative log of the
probability value itself
and the maximum entropy principle
suggests that we should
maximize the entropy of a probability
distribution that we are trying to
estimate subject to some constraints
where most of the times the constraints
are expectation of some function of the
of the variable or of the space over
which the distribution is defined and we
want the expectations to be equal to the
empirical of the
you know
empirical expectations and these
generally come from data
right this where data comes in into the
maximum entropy principle because they
serve as the as the values to which we
want the constraints to satisfy right so
subject to
subject to these constraints we get an
entire family or an entire class of
probability distributions that satisfy
this constraint right so supposing these
uh you know t 1 and t 2 are like
you know
x and x square so if t 1 of x equals x
t 2 of x equals x square then basically
the constraints that we are trying to
express is the first moment of the data
should be you know some the uh first
moment of the of the
of the data the second moment of the
distribution should be the second moment
of the data and so on and subject to
these constraints we basically have an
infinite number of probability
distributions in general uh because
satisfying just two or three constraints
is is uh is pretty easy and then the
maximum enterprise principle suggests
that among
the class of all these candidate
probability distributions that satisfy
these moments the one that we want to
choose is the one that maximizes entropy
yes question can you clarify what you
mean
so moments are you know so
expectation of x is called the first
moment expectation of x square is the
second moment expectation of x cube is
the third moment and so on
right so um
the the the the
the objective that we want to maximize
is the entropy i think there was also a
question somebody asked where why are we
trying to maximize entropy and why not
maximize variance
maximizing variance for example will
so supposing our probability
distribution is defined on the range
a to b
right finite support now uh if we want a
distribution that has high sensor
uncertainty across then we need
the probability uh pdf look like this
which which uniformly assigns 1 over b
minus a density to all the all the areas
now if you want to just maximize
variance instead of maximizing entropy
then the distribution that we have will
be something like this a and b where
half the masses here have the masses
here
right so this maximizes variance
but it does not necessarily mean that
you're maximizing uncertainty right so
maximizing variance does not necess is
not something that we want to do if we
want to just increase our uncertainty
and and and um kind of stay unbiased
about our estimate of of uh what the
probability distribution is right so uh
maximum entropy principles
tells us that satisfy these constraints
and among the all the distribution that
satisfy is choose the one that has the
highest entropy and we saw that this is
equal to this kind of dual problem where
the dual problem is maximum likelihood
where we want to if we were to start
from another direction where we want to
perform maximum likelihood
and the
the the probability distribution if we
assume is part of the exponential family
where the sufficient statistics of the
exponential family are basically the
constraints that we want to satisfy then
these two problems are equivalent
in other words maximum entropy
naturally gives rise to the exponential
family uh
exponential family of probability
distributions right and then we kind of
saw this this somewhat related topic
called calibration which is now super
important if you're building uh you know
real world
predictive models real world forecasting
models so calibration is this property
where the predicted probabilities
you know match the observed frequencies
where when you when you when you say
that some some outcome has a probability
of you know say 80 percent let us say it
is going to rain tomorrow with
probability 80 percent then if you
collect the set of all predictions where
the prediction was 80 percent then
approximately 0.8 fraction of those
true outcomes it actually should have
rained right not more not less it should
have the the uh fraction of observed uh
outcomes should match the predicted
probability that's that then that then
that
model is then said to be well calibrated
against against that distribution
and we also saw that
calibration and accuracy are kind of
orthogonal one does not necessarily
imply the other you can have you know
well calibrated models that are you know
that have very poor accuracy and vice
versa
and
related to this
concept of calibration there is this
concept called a proper scoring rule so
you can think of loss functions as being
a proper scoring rule if they take
a forecast distribution and some actual
outcome
that was observed and kind of
basically give a score to the forecaster
based on what the actual outcome was
right and you can think of it as a loss
function where you know the smaller the
score the better the forecaster was
right and a proper scoring rule is one
that satisfies this property where given
any two probability distributions p and
q you know where if we assume q is like
the
real world occurrence uh or the real
world uh probability distribution of the
true probability distributions and if
x's are being sampled from this you know
real world and
these
real world samples are used to to score
the
score the forecasters probability
distribution where you know
these are the predictions
then
only when the
only when the prediction is the true
probability the loss will be the lowest
for any other probability distribution
being uh predicted if the true events
are sampled from q then the expected
expected score
for the other forecast will always be
higher than the expected score for the
uh true function being a true
distribution
being forecasted right so this is called
a problem proper scoring rule and if we
build models that optimize for proper
scoring rules that is if if our loss
function is penalizing our prediction p
using some proper scoring rule
you know and and subject to few other
you know
constraints it's easy to see that uh
that that
proper scoring rules encourages our
model to predict probabilities that are
forecasted because we are minimized at
at uh we are minimized when the
predicted probability equal to the real
world uh occurrence of data
right and uh
we saw the connection to maximum entropy
of this proper scoring rule that if we
satisfy if we strive to maximize the
entropy or use the maximum entropy
principle then as a consequence the
last function that we get is going to be
the negative log p of x and that's
that's that comes directly from this you
know we are trying to maximize this
instead we can minimize negative
log
p of x right so the negative log
likelihood is just the loss function of
the maximum likelihood objective and we
saw that
if you know f of p x equals n
negative log p of x is a proper scoring
rule because you know if we just plug
minus log p of x here and uh take it to
the other side or you know bring that
to the other side we get that kl
divergence is always greater than equal
to zero which is um you know
which is true that we've also seen that
in the homework so essentially
the the uh the big picture is that
maximum entropy principle
encourage us to
make calibrated predictions right that's
that's the big story from from last
class any questions on this before we
move on to today's topics
okay cool so today uh we'll switch gears
and talk about variational auto encoders
and the first
the first step in this journey will be
to have a look at what auto encoders are
in general
so to study auto encoders we again go
back to neural networks right so in
neural networks
so the the only kind of neural networks
that you studied so far are those that
can be used in a supervised setting
where
we have some we start with some input
layer
we started with some input layer and
then we had all these hidden layers
right
fully connected
at fully connected layers
and we
ended up with a single scale or y hat
and we compared it against you know the
ground truth y or the true label y and
out of these two we constructed a loss
right and
this was a scalar and then we ah
minimize the loss
that
gave us a scalar valued function as a
function of all the parameters and then
we basically
you know
optimize the loss by performing gradient
descent on our last function and in
order to calculate gradient descent with
respect to all the parameters we will we
use the uh multivariate calculus chain
rule which was essentially the same as
back propagation right that's that's uh
that's what we did in supervised
learning setting
instead
now what we are going to do is
we are only given x's
so our training set is now just a set of
x's x 1 through
x n there is no y
and the goal
with auto encoders
the goal with auto encoders is to
learn a way
in which
we introduce something called as a
bottleneck
and reconstruct the original data what i
mean by that is we start with the
original with the input layer being x
right and this used to be d dimensional
right and this will still be d
dimensional
right so this is the input layer
and then we
have a few fully connected layers
right
and we bring it down to some k
dimensional
hidden layer
let us call it z
right and from this k dimensional hidden
layer
we start where typically k is smaller
than d
from here we start
increasing
the
dimensions of the hidden layers
until we are back to d dimensional
d dimensional layer
and
this
layer will call it x hat
and our loss will now be to
to minimize x hat minus
x
right so we want the output of our
network to be the input itself
this may sound trivial
you know because you know all what the
network has to do is to you know take
the input and give the same thing as the
output but
the the challenge for the network is
that it has to basically
take this data transformation through
this bottleneck layer z
which has dimension k which is much
smaller than d right what this what this
ah encourages the model to do is to
learn some kind of a low dimensional
representation of our high dimensional
input data
and then starting with this low
dimensional representation
we map it back into the high dimensional
high dimensional data itself
right and if the model is able to
successfully minimize this loss you know
to a satisfactory level then essentially
the model has learned to compress data
into some kind of
some kind of a latent state or or a
hidden state right so
here
we typically call the parameters of the
first half of the network let us call
these parameters as fee so these are all
the weights and biases of all the layers
until you know the hidden layer that we
are interested in and let us call
the
weights and biases of all the layers
starting from this
hidden layer z all the way until x hat
which is the reconstruction to be lets
call it theta
right and so the loss is now essentially
you know sum over i equals one to n
where small n is the number of examples
we want to minimize the norm between
x i
minus
let us give them names so
this part of the network which takes as
input x and outputs z
let's call it the encoder
right so it encodes data into some
hidden representation z
and we'll call the second half of the
network that takes z as the input and
outputs x hat as the output
we'll call that the decoder
right and the encoder is parameterized
by fee and the decoder is parameterized
by theta
right so now the loss is
ah x minus x hat minus
so first we want to encode
x i
and the parameter here is phi
and we want to take this you know this
is essentially equal
we can call this z i
right and then we want to
take the zi and and feed it as input to
the decoder
right so
we feed this into the decoder
and this decoder is parameterized by
theta
right and this this ah the version that
comes out of the decoder that is the the
original x
encode it through the encoder and decode
that encoding back from the decoder now
this whole thing is x hat i
okay
so we want to minimize the norm between
x i and x hat i
where the loss
is a function of theta and phi
right
so this objective is basically the uh
uh gives you what is called as the auto
encoder we call it an auto encoder
because we want to encode something and
decode it back to the same thing right
which which is where the word auto comes
in and
the way we we go about training this is
through
back propagation right ah
this is going to be a scalar loss
because it's the norm of a vector or the
norm squared of a vector so we are
starting with you know some kind of a
scalar loss
so ah you can you can think of this as
you know
you you come to
an encoded state and decode it back
into
x hat
and
decode it back into x hat
and we have provided a second copy of x
itself
so this is
d dimensional this is d dimensional so
start from the input encode it decode it
you get x hat take the
take the original another copy of x and
using these two construct the last to be
x minus x hat
square
and this is a scalar loss
this will be in r
right and this gives us a loss function
against which we can now perform back
propagation
and train all the model parameters phi
and theta these are basically the
weights and biases in the first half and
the second half of the network
and the way you go about doing
back propagation is exactly how we saw
in the in the neural network lectures
yes question
good question so the the question is you
know how is this different from pca
right in pca we are doing something very
similar we start with a
d-dimensional data and project it uh
down into a low a k-dimensional uh
hidden representation and then um in in
pca we
the the objective there was the to
minimize the the distance between
uh between every point and its
projection right uh the the the main
difference between pca and an auto
encoder is that in pca the
transformation from x to z is strictly
linear
right here you can have multiple hidden
layers which have multiple
non-linearities
so yes so so technically you uh
you could perform a
pca with this thing
um except in pca you might also require
this um would you need the x hat mapping
should this be the inverse you can you
can do something very similar to pci
with this without nonlinearities yeah
you can do it
so this is not the same as pca because
here you know things can be non-linear
the reason why you would want to do the
uh
to do this with data in real life is
because you want to you want to learn
some kind of
a useful hidden representation that has
some kind of a latent meaning right
um and uh we will see with variational
auto encoders of how this uh z
representation is kind of uh you know
where where the the uh hidden
representation with variational auto
encoders will will uh end up having some
kind of a meaning we'll
we'll see later today
right so this is this is uh variational
auto encoders and think of this you can
know in a simplistic term think of this
as dimensionality reduction or
ah you know a way in which you're just
learning some kind of
a compact representation for your data
there are variations of auto encoders
called denoising auto encoders where in
denoising auto encoders
you you learn how to denoise your data
by training
by feeding some kind of a noisy version
of the input and in the loss
so so in the you feed a noisy version of
the input but try to recover the
original x right and that gives you
something called as the denoising auto
encoder where the the uh
where the network learns to denoise the
training data and you know hopefully
generalizes to denoising unseen data as
well right so that's that's uh there are
many variants to uh the auto encoder
okay any questions on this uh this is
all we're going to talk about auto
encoders and we're going to switch to a
different topic yes
so there are no labels here
so the the the task here is to not
predict a label but the task here is to
go through this bottleneck and
reconstruct the original data itself
that's the task
so the question is if if we consider z
to be the output of the first
first uh half of the network what should
the output and the answer is whatever
the network realizes is the optimum z
that helps it recover back x hat
right it is the the uh we are not we we
are not providing any kind of
supervision of what z should be
all we are saying is
whatever z comes out of the first half
should be the z that you feed into the
second half that that performs good
reconstruction of x
yes another question yeah so two
questions should
are p and theta related
no ph and theta are just two different
parameters they're not necessarily
related
no we we don't assume p and theta to be
goal going to inverses like somehow to
detach the second half of it and use
that as a compression
yeah so so the the eventual goal is uh
uh to
to use only the first half on unseen
data to get their you know hidden
representations or their compact
representations so you can you can you
know chop your network at this point and
use it as an encoder where you're
getting some kind of a compressed uh
compressed representation
yeah so so the question is you know
what's the dimension of z what's the you
know uh how many layers do we have those
are all those are all hyper parameters
that you want to that you want to tune
where you can you can train with you
know your training data and see how well
the reconstruction is happening on a
test data and you know you can kind of
do your bias variance analysis there
this question uh
right so uh a relation to factor
analysis let's take that offline uh
that's that's kind of uh uh tangential
to our our topic right now but you know
i'm happy to answer that uh after the
lecture right so um
the this is this is uh the auto encoder
and we'll come back to auto encoder in
in a few minutes in the in the mean time
uh a few more related topics for for our
build up
so next uh so this was auto encoders
2
m c m c
e m
right so um
a quick recall of e m so in em
we
we perform this iterative procedure of
going through two steps the e step and
the m step over and over again until we
converge where the e step
was
for
all
i
where i is indexing your data elements
set
q
i of z will be equal to
p of
z given
x i
under the current parameter theta
and then ah to
make this more clear let us also give
time indexes so at the teeth iteration
we use theta t
right and in the m step
we perform
theta
t plus 1
to be equal to
i'm just going to write it for one
example
but you know it's basically just the sum
over all examples
arg
max
theta
of the elbow i'm going to write out the
elbow in in full form
sum over z
q
t
of z
times
log
p of
x
z
parameterized by theta
over
q i
t of
z
all right
ah
this in fact i am just writing it in
terms of one example all right let me
just write in terms of all the examples
so i equals one to n
you have
x i
z i
right
and c i here
and um in this we can make a
a few comments first of all we assume
that we we could perform this posterior
calculation p of z given x we could
calculate this uh somehow right this is
kind of an implicit assumption in e m
that we can calculate this posterior
distribution p of z even x right that
may or may not hold true in practice
right so that was
that was kind of a big assumption that
we kind of quietly swept it under the
rug and assumed we could you know
calculate the posterior distribution
somehow
now the challenge comes when you're
considering you know complex models for
example suppose suppose our model is
something like this right so z comes
from some normal distribution with mean
0
and i k times k
right
a continuous latent variable z and let's
say
x given z
is
some kind of a thats a neural network
right
neural
network with parameter theta
that takes in as input z
right so z is see z is is sampled from
some gaussian distribution and we feed
that gaussian distribution so imagine
the second half of this network
right we feed that z
into a neural network and out will come
our data
the data that we observe right in this
kind of a setting where our model
is
is so complex that calculating p of z
given x
is pretty much you know impossible
there's no way we can you know take take
some arbitrary neural network and
calculate the posterior of z given x in
in a closed form estimate
right it need not be a neural network it
could be any kind of you know some
complex model
some complex
z i is parameterized by theta right this
could be hierarchical it could be you
know any any kind of a complex model
now the question is how do we
perform em in the setting to estimate
our parameters theta
right because we are no longer able to
come up with a close form estimate for p
of z given uh z given x
right and this is where um
we can make a few observations
so first of all in e m
in the m step
we are holding q fixed right we saw this
previously as well the only
place where
the variable that we are optimizing this
theta the only place it shows up is over
here
right you while you are performing this
as arc max this is the only theta that
we are adjusting to perform the r max
right everything else here are constants
right and so
we can write this as
i think we mentioned uh this
earlier as well that we can all in e m
the m step can always be written as
1 to n
sum over z
q i
t of
vi
log
p of
x i
z i
rise by theta
right
these two are always the same will
always
are equivalent because
log of a by b can be written as log a
minus log b and log b is essentially a
constant with respect to theta so we can
just get rid of the denominator inside
the log
right and now
you know if you look at this
in this form we kind of get another
insight the insight is that
even though we wanted to ca you even
though in the e step we say we want to
calculate q
the probability distribution of of the
posterior of z
we don't really want to calculate the
density values itself
right the only way q gets used in the m
step
is to ca is to ah is to construct this
expectation right so this is
i equals one to n
expectation of
z i coming from
q
i of t of
log p
x i
z i
theta
okay
r max
so
even though q i appears in this in this
expression it is only used to take an
expectation of this function right we do
not really need to calculate the density
by itself we are only interested in the
density of uh density values of q only
to perform this expectation
right and using this insight that the
purpose of q is only to take the
expectation
we can instead
what we can do is to approximate this
arc max theta
sum over i equals 1 to n
and over here what we are going to do
is to replace the expectation
with the monte carlo estimate of the
expectation and what that means is
instead of integrating over this
function using the density of q instead
we will take many many samples of z from
q
right
and average take the average of this
across all those samples of z right so
that would look something like this um
let's assume we take capital t number of
samples for each example and this would
be
one over capital t
t is probably a bad choice so let's call
it capital m
you know so we're going to use
capital m number of samples for each
monte carlo expectation estimate ah
small m equals 1 through capital m
log
p
of
x i
and z in place of z i i'm going to write
z
m
where z m
is
z
m
of i is sampled from
q
i of t
right so we rewrite this expectation
as a monte carlo estimate
where the z's are sampled from q's
the cues however is still this posterior
but there are many techniques to sample
from a posterior of a complex
probability distribution even though we
don't know how to evaluate it there are
techniques
such as you know gibbs sampling
or
metropolis hastings
so so
mcmc is a vast vast vast field where
there are many techniques for sampling
from posteriors even though we don't
know how to exactly calculate the
density of a given point in the
posterior but we can still get samples
right and basically the law of large
numbers tells us that as m goes to
infinity
this monte carlo estimate
will tend to will converge towards the
true expectation
right and so
with this technique
you know this this is a variant of em
where you know even though we do we we
don't know how to calculate uh uh the
posterior distribution we can
approximate the posterior using monte
carlo techniques or sampling techniques
right so this is this is one way to to
work around uh
complex
or hard to compute posteriors
any questions on this
this question
the last step
yeah so in the last step what we are
doing is
we are replacing this expectation
with the monte carlo estimate of the
expectation
right so we replace this expectation
with the monte carlo estimate of the
expectation
where did the q go q is is is a
distribution from which the zi's are
sampled
right so over here z i was sampled from
q and this was an analytical expression
for the expectation instead we replace
it with the monte carlo estimate of this
expectation where zi's are sampled from
q and we sample capital m number of such
samples from a qi and construct this
average of this function for using those
samples as the monte carlo estimate of
the expectations
yes if as you take m to infinity then
these two will evaluate to the same
value right and that's the law of large
numbers
right so
the original em
we constructed a convergence proof
where with every e and m step the
likelihood was only increasing
right we we we saw that uh proof with
you know likelihood construct the lower
bound and then construct a lower bound
in another lower bound and at every step
we were guaranteed that you know the the
the
theta t's were increasing the likelihood
but over here that guarantee does not
hold anymore
right because this is an approximation
and not an approximation of the
lower bound and not and not the exact
core bond this question
so with gibb sampling you can sample the
posterior samples from the posterior
so you we get samples of zs
right and using the sample values of
these we can take the average of the of
the joint
good question
right so this is this is one approach to
ah to addressing interactable posteriors
through this technique called sampling
right and there is you there is this
other kind of counterpart approach
for
approximating complex posteriors which
is called variational inference
right
so to
when you want to calculate posterior
distributions you basically have three
choices
choice number one is the exact posterior
like you know use math algebra use bayes
rule and and and calculate the exact
posterior
if that is not possible you are left
with two other choices choice number two
is to approximate it using gibbs
sampling or or
through some kind of a sampling approach
a monte carlo approach
where you take samples and take the
expectation of the thing you want to you
want to
take the expectation off with respect to
the posterior
option number three is variational
inference so variational inference is
another technique to
to work around these interactable
posteriors
and in order to kind of
understand variational inference
we
go back to
we go back to the expression we derived
in em
which was basically
log p of x
was greater than or equal to
alpha
of
x
with some q
right we derived this using jensen's
inequality
and we left it at this form saying lo
you know uh the elbow is a lower bound
of the uh
of the
log probability of the evidence right
it's the lower bound of the evidence
but how much is it lower by
right
so the question is log p of x
is equal to
alpha of x
plus
what
right and in fact the the answer is
pretty straight forward all what you
want to do is take this to the other
side and you get this is equal to
log p of x minus
elbow
right
and the elbow
is basically this form
and you plug in this form over here
i'm not going to do the do the algebra
it's pretty straight forward very simple
algebra what you get over here is
basically the kl divergence between q
and
p of z given x
right and this should not be surprising
because when q
is equal to p of z given x
we saw that the elbow is tight and will
be exactly equal to log p of x
right
so it could have been the kl divergence
from p to q or q to p you know one of
those two are the natural choices but if
you work out the algebra it turns out
that it is you know the kl divergence
from q to p p of c given x
right so
our our ah goal is to
estimate log p of z even x
right
and here we are making this observation
that
you know um
the kl divergence between q and p is z
given x is equal to you know uh this
value over here
so this is basically kind of uh uh
the motivation for how we derive the
variational inference ah so for
variational inference what we see is
uh
log p of x
does not have any q term in it
right so this is effectively a constant
so log
p of x
is basically a constant it has
it has no no q term in it and then we
[Applause]
and then we have the elbow
of x
q plus
d k l of
q to p of
z given x
right so this is a constant with respect
to q
with respect to
q
and this has a q term and this has a q
term
and
we want our q
to be exactly equal to p of z given x
right
and or um
that that is that's our eventual goal or
the the ideal goal that z is equal to p
of z given x but instead with uh
variational inference what we what we do
is we
in order to make it as close to p of z
given x as possible
we maximize this with respect to q
now if we maximize this with respect to
q
make this observation that this
is greater than or equal to 0 so for no
value of q will this become negative
right no matter what q we choose will
that become negative if we choose the
best possible q then this just this term
just becomes
0.
so
instead of
calculating p of z given x
somehow
we take this variational approach where
we say
q of z given or q of
or rather p of z given x
next we approximated
by
the
arc max
of q in some family
of
the elbow
of x
comma q
right
if we maximize the elbow as much as
possible with respect to q
we are bounded by log p of x anyways
right so this provides like a ceiling
and if we maximize the elbow as much as
possible because this is non-negative
highest possible we can take this
when we maximize this completely
with respect to q we would have
naturally
obtained a q that minimized the kl
divergence between q and p p of z equal
next
does that make sense
right so
performing arg max of this elbow over q
will give us a q that is very close to p
of z given x
and
this kind of an approach
where we maximize this lower bound with
respect to q and obtain a distribution
which we approximated to be p of z z
unix is called variational inference
right and this is
you know ah a kind of
a
complementary approach to
the sampling based approaches because in
sampling based approaches
you could take an infinite number of
exam of of samples and eventually
you would get the you would recover the
exact uh
evidence lower bound you would recover
the exact elbow as you took m to
infinity
right whereas over here
most of the times
we will not take out the exact
posterior
but we will end up having some kind of
an approximation of p of z given x
depending on how flexible this family of
q is
right and over here
the technique we used for sampling
whereas with
variational inference that the technique
we use is optimization
right in sampling we do you know
sampling in monte carlo techniques we do
sampling with variational inference we
do optimization here in the limit
we recover the exact solution
whereas over here
we always get an approximate solution
depending on you know how flexible the
the family queue is
over here if you're familiar with monte
carlo techniques you never know how good
your estimate is you know you need to
keep taking more and more samples all
you know is eventually
you will reach
the exact solution but at any given time
say you you've taken you know 100
samples they have taken 10 million
samples that you don't know how good or
how close you are to the true
expectation right you're just told that
eventually you will be
but this technique
will converge
right you know when to stop when this
when this maximization you know um
when when you complete this optimization
problem you know that you know you know
when to stop you know that the solution
is approximate but you know when to stop
whereas over here you don't know when to
stop
right so those are like you know the the
the trade-offs between
between uh monte carlo techniques and
variational inference techniques or the
sampling techniques versus variation
inference techniques yes
yeah so the you know the queue that you
end up here you're going to plug it in
over here
yeah you can think of this as the first
part where you recover a queue using
variational inference and use that queue
to construct your
m-step objective
right and ah
whereas over here uh you constructed the
m step
objective or the proxy to the m step
objective through sampling whereas here
you know the proxy was through this
approximation of
from from the variational inference step
right and this technique
of constructing the m-step objective
using a proxy queue instead of the exact
posterior cue
will give rise to something that's
called variational em
right in both mcmcem and variational em
the the goal is to work around the
construction of the exact posterior
right in mcm cem we worked around it
using sampling
monte carlo sampling or gibbs gibb
sampling in variational em we worked
around the exact posterior using
variational inferences
so so i guess the question is you know
uh uh suggesting a technique of how we
can check whether mcmc has conversed uh
uh i'll not go deep into i'll not go
deeper into that we can we can discuss
that offline but uh in general it's a
hard problem when you're running monte
carlo techniques to know you know um
whether you you kind of um so so the the
technical term there is something called
as a burn-in phase
where first you know you start with some
kind of an initialization and you don't
know how good it is so you want to you
know first discard some samples and then
hopefully after the burning phase where
which is hard to calculate whether the
burning phase is over or not hopefully
from then you're getting you know
samples from the true posterior and then
it becomes a question of how many you
want but in general calculating whether
the burden phase is over or not is is
kind of a a hard problem
all right so
the two so uh in in in the standard em
you calculate the exact posterior using
you know math and you know analytical
expressions
if that is hard you you're left with two
options one option is
mcm cem where you approximate the m step
with uh you approximate the m step with
uh uh
the expectation the m step with the
monte carlo expectation
and in variational em which is the other
approach you know uh you can you
construct an approximation of q
from some family capital q
and you use that the the um
the recovered queue from optimization
and construct you know the uh the m-step
proxy by using the queue that came from
the variation stream yes question
uh monte carlo uh markov chain monte
carlo that's the you know the techniques
you use are called mcmc techniques to
obtain samples
right
right so now um
a few more details about
variational inference and then we can
we can start talking about the variation
auto encoder
so in in variational inference
most of the time the question is how do
we choose the family queue from which we
want to perform optimization
and a common
uh family of of uh
of probability distributions
is to
so remember z so the q distribution that
we are are trying to recover in
variational inference is over zs and z
is a vector in rk right it's a k
dimensional vector
so our probability distribution
must be a distribution over
k vectors or or vectors of dimension k
right and
high dimensional
probability distributions are
quite few you do not have as many
probability distributions as
distributions over scalar values
and
a common assumption
made in variational inference is to
assume that
q of z
are the the family
of distributions from which you want to
perform the
optimization q of z where
z is in you know think of it as an rk
can be factored into
components
q1 of z1 times
q2 of z2 times
q k of
z k
right we're going to assume
if we assume that the components
of the
of the z vector
can be factored into independent scalar
probability distributions so if we make
this assumption which is a common
assumption that is made
then
there is a name given to ah
given to this assumption it is called
mean field assumption
mean field assumption and variational
inference that uses this kind of a
factorize this kind of a factorization
is called mean field variation inference
and
the roots into why
we make this assumption is is beyond
beyond the scope uh for those who are
interested uh okay so the obvious first
you know the most simple reason is that
it makes computation easier
right you're you're
making strong independence assumptions
but you know you get a computational
ease in return
and there are other uh
you know good reasons why this uh this
can be done in certain cases for example
so so the mean field variational
inference actually comes from
statistical physics where you know
variational influence was kind of
i guess it was
invented in in statistical physics where
you make this mean field assumption and
that kind of holds well in statistical
physics for
whatever reasons but you know
it may or may not hold on your data
but you know it's still commonly done
because it makes computation easy
and in fact the word mean field uh comes
from statistical physics where you know
um
from from you know field theory and what
not in statistical physics where they
make these approximations that
things are things are independent
however we're going to
you're going to call all the techniques
that make this assumption as mean field
techniques
where
the queue that we are trying to
the family queue where we are trying to
perform the maximization
can be factored into these individual
components
and this mean field technique
mean field assumption is something that
we're going to use in
variational auto encoders
right so we
this is just a name
variation auto encoders
so if you remember in e m
in e m
we
we constructed this elbow
right and the elbow had a q
and parameter theta
right in the e step we would
find the best possible q which is the
posterior and in the m step um
we would we would update theta
uh in the uh to recover uh the next uh
the next estimate of theta and while
performing each of these steps in the e
step while we were calculating the next
q we would hold theta fixed
and in the m step when we were
calculating the next theta we would hold
q fixed
right and that is a technique that is
also called coordinate ascent
right in coordinate ascent or coordinate
descent
our objective has multiple variables
and the way we go about optimizing it is
to start with some initialization hold
most of them fixed or all except one
fixed or all except you know a subset
fixed
and by holding them fixed optimize the
ones that we have not held fixed
and once you
obtain their updated estimate then hold
the updated estimates fixed and you know
optimize the other ones and so on
so one way to think of it is
you know if this is um
q
and
and and theta
and supposing this is the contour plot
of elbow of the elbow
right we start with some let us say we
start with some point over here
right and we up we hold q fixed and
optimize it with respect to theta
and we reach some point over here
and then we
hold theta fixed and optimize it with
respect to q
and we some point here and then we hold
q fixed and optimize with respect to
theta and then whole theta fix optimize
it with respect to q and so on uh where
we are updating only one of the axes at
a time and this is called basically a
coordinate ascent
where we are trying to kind of climb
this hill of this contour plot of the uh
of the elbow by moving in only one
direction at a time so we are either
moving north south or moving east west
right and and uh keep moving until
you've kind of reached the local optima
along that direction and stop there and
then start moving you know north south
until you reach a local optima and then
again east west until you reach local
optima and so on so that's coordinator
cent
and this coordinate ascent kind of
worked well with
with with classical em where the
optimization along the q step
was not gradient assigned but we were
just calculating the posterior right so
calculating the posterior so starting
from this and just calculating the new q
which is the posterior corresponding to
this value of theta was the
e step right so so the e step
moves this way and the m step moves this
way
right
now using this kind of uh coordinate uh
ascent
you know if we ask the question
can we do gradient descent instead you
know what does that even mean
right instead of doing coordinate
descent can we do gradient descent
and and that basically
ah
gives rise to
the variational auto encoder so in the
variational auto encoder
we are going to
maximize the elbow using gradient ascent
and the way we go about doing it we're
going to first assume that
the distribution from our our the model
is something like this so we're going to
assume z
comes from
some normal distribution
k times k
right so thats ah thats thats where z
comes from
and then
z comes from that and
x given z
comes from some normal distribution
whose mean is given by
a function
g of
z parameterized by theta
and we can assume some kind of
fixed
fixed variance
right
so z z is the is is like the um
latent variable so z is sampled from
some
some normal distribution this is the
prior
and x given z think of this the
likelihood
right
[Applause]
and now
in order to in order to ah
perform the
the e step
we need to get the posterior
right so the posterior is you know
if we have access to it it would be
p of z given x right
but but but if with this kind of uh
a model where
g
is a
neural network
with
parameter theta
it's very hard to to calculate p of z
given x you are probably never going to
be able to obtain a p of z given x uh in
a closed form estimate
so when we don't have an exact solution
basically we have two other options
sampling or variational inference right
and the the techniques that's used in
the variation auto encoder is you know
not
surprisingly variational inference right
which is why we call it the variational
auto encoder so we want to estimate or
approximate p of z unit x using
variational inference
and the way we go about doing
variational inference
is that the family q
q family
for
variational inference
right we need to choose a family for
doing variational inference
and that
family is basically
q i is equal to
normal distribution with mean
small q
x i
comma
phi
and
diagonal
of
v of
x i
comma
psi
now what does this mean
right so first we spoke about
having families of distributions
for for performing variational inference
but in
the the the distribution
or the family of distributions
on which we perform variational
influence
we would get a different q distribution
for example
right in in
in
in e m
the e step is performed separately for
each example
however here what we are doing is
we are recognizing the fact that
q i depends on x you know because q i is
supposed to be p of z given x
and we are going to approximate the q
distribution across all examples using a
neural network
right so the neural network will take x
as the input
and output the mean and variance of a
normal distribution for the
corresponding example qi for the
corresponding example i
and this is
sometimes called amortized inference
right because ah the the uh the
difference between em and uh
the variation auto encoder here is that
in em we were separately calculating the
parameters of the queue distribution for
each example separately and
independently right we would calculate q
ah
just going to pull this here to
2
right
in em we would loop over each example
and for each example separately we would
calculate p of z given x i
right and once you calculate that you
know keep it aside pick the next example
and repeat this and calculate the q
distribution for that example
right and we would do that independently
for each example whereas with
with amortized inference what we instead
do is
we are not going to calculate a separate
posterior distribution for each example
instead what we are going to do is
we are going to we are going to assume
that all queues come from a normal fam
belong to a normal distribution
and
each of these
the mean and variance of
each qi
is going to be a function of your x's
right they're going to be function of
your axis the mean and variance of each
qi is going to be a function of the xs
and those functions are essentially
neural networks
right so feed x as the input
and the neural network will output two
scalars
per input
one scalar is the or one vector will be
the mean the other vector will be
the variance so your q network would
look something like this you know take x
as the input
right and you will have a few layers
right
and
as the final layer
you will get
mu
right so the mean
and we call this q
right parameterized by phi
so
feed uh q phi this entire network right
this is q
parameterized by phi so phi represents
all the weights and biases of this
network so the input to this network is
an example x i
and the output of this network is some
vector mu i
x i was in rd
mu i is in
rk
and this mu i
will be used as the mean of a normal
distribution where this normal
distribution represents q i
next question
so there's no bottleneck here we are
just mapping it from x to mu right
there's no bottleneck here these could
be
any dimensions right we just need to go
from x to z
this is not an auto encoder yet it's
just some network that takes you from x
to z's there is no bottleneck here
this question
yeah k is generally less than d yes
that's the uh general assumption because
uh in general your latent latent uh the
latent representations will always have
a compact representation so z's will be
of dimension uh k k by k and x is and
and this will be in
rd
yes
so q is a distribution over z so the
question is why is
mu
a smaller dimension that's because q is
a distribution over z
and z is k dimensional so the mean has
to be k dimensional
right so this
should be in rk the mean should be
in rk because z is in rk
right and the the covariance should be
in r of
k times k
right
this question
so the the thing we discussed in the
beginning was was just auto encoders all
the way at the beginning
that was not variational auto encoders
so this is the model so why is this
justified this is the this is the mod we
are starting with you know we are not
proving anything we are we're assuming
if this is the model
and and and seeing what the consequences
are
yeah so uh you know i would say you know
hold off making connections to auto
encoders for a moment we'll put them all
together and see the connection soon
right so for now z is some hidden layer
you're right eventually this will be
like the the bottleneck layer but for
now uh assume you know just like in
factor analysis and factor analysis z
was some k you know k dimensional uh
vector and x given z was something else
so in place of that assume you have a
model like this
right
so we go from
from x which is an rd down to rk and
that will be the mean
right yes
matrix i'm going to come to the
covariance now
so that gave us the mean
for the covariance
instead what we're going to do is
have something very similar instead of q
we're going to call it v
right so
again we are starting with x in
r d
and have some kind of a network
right
and and over here
you are going to get
v
again
in r
k
right and this v
we are then going to make it positive
because standard deviations and
variances are always positive
and there are many techniques you can
use to take any number and make it
positive one approach is to just square
them
another approach is to exponentiate each
element
and both are both are commonly done
so this v
is is generally taken to be
let's call the last layer as you know i
don't know u
u right
generally the last layer of the of the
variance network is taken to be
you know e to the u
element wise
right to get positive standard
deviations
right and this
this vector of length k
is then converted into a diagonal matrix
where we have v one
v two
and v k
and this will be k by k
and this matrix is used as the
covariance matrix of qi
we have two different models there um
two different networks uh to to take us
from x to one parameter and x to another
parameter
in practice what's commonly done is to
have a single
network
where everything until the last layer is
shared and at the last layer you have a
separate branch
so one branch for the mean one branch
for the for the variance
because we need
two parameters for
for for a normal distribution
we need a mu and we need a covariance
and and you can you can you can get all
of them as the output from the last
layer that's that's that's also totally
fine
that there's not much difference between
having you know distinct networks versus
having one network where you kind of
split the last layer into different
parameters both both work totally
i could fine how that q function
describes this family of q because the
model is the same but i don't understand
how you derive this from a separate
model like the variance of it
so so the variance of this yeah yeah so
so um essentially q i
so the question is you know why do we i
guess you know why do we have two
networks i guess that's
at the heart of the question so the the
the qi we define it to be a normal
distribution and in order to define a
normal distribution you need two
parameters right so for each example we
need two parameters a mean and a
variance
for another example another mean and a
variance
and because they are in high dimensional
space the mean and variance will be a
vector and a matrix
right for another for take a new example
you need a new mean vector and a new
covariance matrix right e the the mean
a covariance pair is per example
and the wave instead of
separately estimating them for each
example
we are going to perform amortized
inference which means
recognizing the fact that they depend on
x we try to capture the relation using a
shared network
where you feed in x and the output is
the mean vector
feed in x and the output is a covariance
matrix
instead of calculating them separately
this technique is called amortized
inference
right and
instead of estimating all the all the
means and all the means and variances
separately we instead learned the
parameters fee and decide
yes question
actually as you mentioned in case of the
queue we use a parameterized by the tree
yes and
in case of the v we parameterize the
other
yeah so the question is here we use the
notation that phi is parameterized q is
parameterized by phi and here it's
parameterized by psi
and i also mentioned that you can share
all the layers uh and and have just uh
you know the last layer separate if we
do the shared layer then this notation
does not work
right so uh the
the
according to this notation we we just
have two different networks
right and these parameters are psi and
these parameters are fee
right
but you can you can you know in practice
what's commonly done is you don't have
two completely separate networks right
they go these two will have shared
parameters
this question
assuming that
you kind of
completely made
right so the the um
we're going to have these two networks
which you know when you start they are
untrained randomly initialized
you feed in an x whatever you comes out
of
at the other end you use it as the mean
of the q distribution for the e step
right and you have this other network
feed in you get a vector convert it into
a diagonal matrix
and use it as the as the covariance
matrix for the e step of that example so
for each example you feed it once
through this and once through this take
the two parameters and plug it and
construct the
e step of that example right
and now
because we are assuming a gaussian
distribution
and because we are
having a diagonal covariance matrix
so gaussian distributions have this
property that
uncorrelated that if there is no
correlation between two components of a
joint uh uh gaussian then they
necessarily must be independent right
the gaussian distribution is probably
the only one maybe there are others but
i think it's only the gaussian that have
this property that if you take a joint
gaussian
gaussian vector and two components of
the o of the of that joint have
are uncorrelated have zero covariance
then the two are necessarily independent
right so
this diagonal covariance matrix
means
we are using
we are making
the mean field assumption
so because we have a here we are
constructing a diagonal matrix from a
vector we are and we are using a normal
distribution we are effectively doing
mean field variational inference where
we are assuming that each of the zi's
are independent
so this is the mean of the zi's and this
is the
these are the variances of the zi's this
question
yeah so you can think uh i i i would say
don't worry too much about this uh uh
squaring because the what you get out of
here is generally the uh uh
the standard deviation and the variance
is basically the square of the standard
deviation that's why i use the notation
here you know just the way in you know
we write you know mean and sigma square
because it's a diagonal element a
diagonal matrix you can think of it as
element wise yes
this question can we just try the models
uh can you please repeat the question
variance instead of standard deviation
yeah you could you know you can treat
this as the variance you can treat this
as a standard deviation that it's it
doesn't make a lot of difference you can
you both both approaches work fine yes
question
right yes the good point so fees and
size are shared across examples
right you feed different examples
through this network the network is the
same the network stays fixed for all
examples the output of the network will
be the mean and variance of the queue
distribution
good point right
so ah
so now we basically have all the all the
missing pieces all or all the pieces to
write out our objective
and there's going to be one final trick
that is required
to finish this up
so remember
we first observed that e m was
coordinate ascent
and now instead we want to do gradient
ascent
and the queues here
are coming through this amortized
inference where we have a single network
that outputs the parameters for each
example rather than having different
different
parameters for each example
in standard em we calculate different
parameters for each example in the e
step
but with amortized influence we just
have one network having shared weights
that outputs
outputs the q parameters for all
examples
right so now
the elbow we can write the elbow like
this
so
the elbow here will be over
p
psi
theta
is equal to
sum over i equals one to n
expectation of z i coming from
q i
log
p of
x i
z i
parameterized by theta
over
q i
of c i
where
q i
is a normal distribution
with mean
q
x i parametrized by v
and
covariance being a diagonal matrix
the v network
which takes input x i
parameter
psi
right so this is our elbow now
the original elbow
so for reference
the e elbow with you know
standard em was
over there the elbow had just q and
theta
and that was
sum over i equals 1 to n
[Music]
let me just write it as
as
expectation
z i from
q i
log
p of x comma z
prime attached by theta and q
i of
z i so this was the
elbow in case of em
where each q
was separately calculated for each
example
as in parallel
however when we move over to amortized
inference
we don't have q and ah and and theta
anymore
we had q because we we would calculate q
separately for each distribution instead
of having separate queues for each uh
distribution we instead have shared
phi and
psi that are shared across examples
right and
the the
the rest of the expression stays the
same
except q qi is now not something that
was independently calculated for each
example but instead we use this
amortized inference technique where we
feed each example to these networks and
the output of the network will become
the parameters of the corresponding q
distribution
right so now we are pretty much
pretty much ready ah in case of em we
would optimize this elbow with
coordinate ascent now we're going to
optimize
this objective with gradient to send
right and the parameters that we want to
optimize are the phi psi and theta
so this means
we want to now maximize um
this elbow with respect to
these parameters which means we want our
update rules to look like this so we
want theta to be
theta plus some learning rate let's call
it um
eta you know this just the learning rate
times the gradient with respect to theta
of elbow
of
psi
p
theta
and
phi is equal to
v plus
gradient with respect to phi
of
basically the same thing
similarly
psi
equal to
psi plus eta times the gradient with
respect to psi
of the elbow
okay you want to do this until
convergence right in em we would do e
step and m step until convergence in
case of the variational auto encoder we
want to perform these gradient updates
until convergence which means in case of
e m we had q's and thetas now we will
have
um
so thetas and here we will have
phi and
psi i'm just writing them together and
you have
some kind of thing you start with you
know some random location and we want to
perform
gradient update
right and
most commonly we do not do gradient
ascent we do stochastic gradient ascend
and now the challenge is how do we
calculate these these gradients right
and once we are able to calculate these
gradients we are effectively done
so the way we go about calculating these
gradients is so the first thing the
gradient with respect to theta
so gradient with respect to theta
of elbow
of
phi
psi theta
is equal to gradient with respect to
theta
of
i equals one to n
expectation of z with respect to q i
of
log p of x
z
parametrized by theta
over
q y of
z
i now how do we take the expectation
of the gradient of
you know some term
under an expectation we just take the
gradient inside the expectation and we
can take the gradient inside the
expectation because the distribution
with which we are taking the expectation
does not depend on theta
right so this
is equal to
some more i equals one to n
expectation
z i from
q i
off
gradient with respect to theta
of
log
log p of
x i x i
z i
x i
z i
theta
and
the denominator will will just cancel
just like in the case of em in case of
em when we were optimizing with respect
to theta the denominator could be
removed
right and this
we will factor it out into p of x ah
p of x comma z is basically p of x given
z times p of z
right and this is equal to i equal to 1
to n
expectation
z i from q i
gradient with respect to theta
log
p of
x i given
z i
parametrized by theta
plus
gradient with respect to theta
log
p of
z i
right and this just
goes to zero
and this p of x given z
if you remember
p of x given z
is our
encoder
right so p of x q and z we assume
takes this
this encoder and this is basically
the
this is basically the log likelihood
using you know
g the encoder
right and we use gray at the back
propagation over here
now
the challenge comes you know this was
pretty straightforward we could just
take the gradient inside the expectation
and everything else
inside was pretty
simple and straightforward
but now comes the challenge for the
other parameters and this is where the
the uh the vae's innovation
comes in
so now if you want to
do with respect to
gradient with respect to
phi
elbow
of
phi
psi theta
is equal to gradient with respect to phi
sum i equals 1 to n
expectation of
z i
from q
i
of
log p of x comma z
to theta
and
of
z i
but now the q
q is basically what we saw is
parameterized by phi and psi
and now if you want to take the gradient
of this objective with respect to phi
then the distribution with respect to
which we are taking the expectation
depends on phi
right in these cases we cannot just swap
the gradient and expectation
and this is where
really the the the kind of key
innovation of the variational auto
encoder comes into picture which is
called the reparameterization trick
right so the reparameterization trick
is something we have seen already in the
past
which is basically
if z
if z comes from some normal distribution
of mean mu and standard deviation
psi we can rewrite z to be equal to
some epsilon
times standard deviation plus mu
where
epsilon comes from a normal distribution
a standard normal distribution
right you're going to you're going to
make use of this special property of
gaussian distributions this is also
called the location scale property where
you can decouple a gaussian random
variable from its parameters
where the randomness
is completely contained in the separate
variable called epsilon
which has mean 0 standard deviation 1
and we can take these parameters and
scale
the standard
standard normal and
move its location to mu
right and now
we are going to rewrite this objective
as the gradient with respect to
phi
sum of i equals
1 to n
this question so are you saying that the
solution
the distribution q i is parameterized by
phi
precisely because q i
mean depends on phi
and this we're going to now rewrite it
as i equals 1 to n
expectation
of
epsilon
coming from some normal
0 1
so we instead of taking expectation with
respect to z we instead take the
expectation with respect to epsilon
which has no parameters
and we are going to write log
of p
of
x comma in place of z
we take epsilon
and the
and the and the uh
epsilon times the variance the standard
deviation plus
the mean
so that will look
this might look a little complex but for
the uh
let me use some simpler notation here so
this we will write it as epsilon
i
times
i am going to write it as
psi
i
plus
mu
i parametrized by theta
divided by
q
of
epsilon i
times
plus
mu i
where
mu i is equal to
q of
x i
phi and
i
is
diagonal
of
v of
x i prime plus pi
right and once we
are able to
rewrite the expectation with respect to
z in terms of expectation with respect
to some epsilon
right and in place of z we are going to
take epsilon and scale it by
you know the covariance matrix and add
the mean vector that comes from q and v
which is basically z so this whole thing
over here
over here is z i
and similarly this whole thing over here
is also z i
where we make use of this this property
to do these replacements
and now
the expectation does not depend does not
have this parameter anymore and this
will now allow us to swap it
and again once we swap it the gradients
can be taken in a straightforward way
so so yeah so so the question is why
isn't our you know where is the loss for
the correct mew i guess
yes uh yeah so uh let's piece it all
together that that hopefully will answer
it right so this gives us a way in which
we can take the the gradient of the
elbow with respect to phi right
taking the gradient of the elbow with
respect to theta was pretty
straightforward because we could swap
the gradient and expectation because the
expectation did not depend on theta in
any ways
but for the other parameters where the
the expectation depends on phi itself
we make use of this reparameterization
trick where in the with the
reparameterization trick we can rewrite
the expectation
from in terms of z to in terms of
epsilon that has no parameters his
question
yes i'm going to come to that right
so now we we replaced
the expectation or with respect to z
with respect with
expectation with respect to epsilon
right
so the question is now
you know piecing this all together
over here
what we see what what what we can see is
we still have even though we were able
to swap the gradient and the expectation
we are still left with the expectations
right so the so the gradients
still have an expectation term left in
it
right which
in general can be a
a problem
but what is done in practice is that
this expectation is approximated with
monte carlo
which means we take a sample
zi from qi
and construct and calculate the the um
and use that as the
input for this encoder neural network
to perform back propagation and back
propagation is performed with respect to
theta
and the output of the neural network
is trained to
be excised
right if you so this is the the you can
think of this as the as the
sorry this should be the decoder i'm
sorry about that
this is the
p of c given x so this should be the
decoder
but in the decoder you're fed the input
zi and the output should be x i
and we the the x i
the uh x i over here
um
instead of g let's give it a different
name it's
so what does the notes use for g so all
right so the note uses g for decoder so
okay so g is fine
so this is
this has
the loss function over here is the
maximum likelihood objective and the
maximum likelihood objective is just the
multivariate gaussian
and
that gives us the loss
right and this is basically you know the
gradient of the loss
of
this multivariate uh gaussian whose
parameters
are theta
whose parameters are the
so so let me just write this clearly so
you can think of this as a neural
network
where the inputs are z's
right
and the output is
x hat
and this x hat
will
is is ah going to be
compared against
x's
right and the uh so this becomes like
the mean of the distribution and x is
going to be the observation and we
assume that the variance is some sigma
square i
and this you plug it in into the you
know log probability of
x i
parameterized by the mu that comes out
of
g of
z i
and the variance is sigma square i right
so
this this log likelihood or the negative
log likelihood becomes the loss
and you know
the input becomes the zi that is sampled
from q
and you feed that zi you get a
corresponding uh corresponding mean and
you assume a constant variance and you
plug it in into uh a gaussian multi
multivariate gaussian
likelihood objective and here p will be
you know 1 over
2 pi to the
d by 2 and you know
the whole thing
right so that's how the uh that's how
things work on the decoder side
where zi's we sample
our sample from from qi but what are qi
here qi
are is the is the is the uh basically
the output of our encoder network so
this was the decoder network
the gradient with respect to a theta was
for the decoder part of the network
and
the picture to have of the two working
together is something like this so
let me do it
right
z is latent
right
x
is observed
now the encoder takes us from x to z
and the decoder takes us from z to x
right
so
in the variational auto encoder we are
using neural networks here and here
there are two different neural networks
this neural network has parameter
phi and psi
right and this is being used as a
replacement for the e step
and over here the decoder neural network
has parameters theta
and this is being used kind of like the
m step
right but we are going to jointly
optimize
both these objectives rather than you
know one at a time
and
the the
uh in order to optimize them with
respect to and the way we optimize them
is by maximizing the elbow
so the elbow is what has
phi
psi
and theta
and we want to calculate the gradient of
this with respect to phi psi and theta
separately and perform gradient descent
and in order to perform
the uh
in order to calculate the gradients we
saw this problem where
the um the gradient with respect to
theta was pretty easy because we could
just swap the expectation and and
and the gradient operator
so uh for the decoder this was easy
you know you can just swap it but for
the encoder
where the expectation depended on phi
and psi
we made use of the reparameterization
trick
vectorization
and after doing the re parameterization
trick for both the gradients we are
still left with an expectation though
right we are still left with an
expectation we were able to swap it
right but we are still left with an
expectation we did not eliminate the
expectation right and
what is done in practice is those
gradients
are approximated using monte carlo
estimates
those expectations of the gradients are
are
approximated with monte carlo
expectations of those gradients
and the way
you you think of
think of it is
so we have the xs
right and you have an encoder
which takes you down to
z
right and from z you have something that
takes you back to
x
right and
in the encoder we saw that the encoder
takes takes ah x as input and in fact it
outputs two components a mu component
so it outputs a new component
and
the
sigma component as a diagonal matrix
right so the encoder takes x as input
and outputs two sets of parameters
now these two sets of parameters
are
so this is x i
these two sets of parameters together
define
qi
right that's that's that's like the uh
posterior
and from this
we are now going to sample a zi because
you know uh
the uh
the gradient has this expectation and
for that we're going to sample the zi's
from these uh from these parameters and
we're going to use the z eyes as input
for the decoder network
right so the encoder has parameter fee
the decoder has parameter theta
and we're going to take these sampled
zis and feed it as input to the decoder
to get
to get the recovered or the
reconstructed axis
and together with with both these
encoder and decoder
networks we are able to
construct the elbow right so the
elbow was
so the elbow was over here
okay so the elbow is over here
and this is p of
x given z times p of z
right and so this is the ah decoder
neural network
right and everywhere where there is a q
i we have the encoder neural networks
right and the way we go about
training
training the variation auto encoder is
to
is to minimize maximize that loss
and
maximize the elbow and we go about
maximizing the elbow by calculating the
gradients and taking gradient uh
gradient percent steps
this question
so i would say this is uh so the
question is can we use any kind of
neural network to do expectation
maximization i would say you know don't
think of this as doing expectation
maximization we are this is an
alternative to expectation maximization
in expectation maximization is defined
as the coordinate ascent approach
right so what we are instead doing here
is we are just trying to fit a latent
variable model
where in
the relation to to em is through this
coordinate ascent versus gradient ascent
interpretation
so the question is is ascent susceptible
to saddle points or local optima uh yes
they are
vae is also susceptible to local optima
absolutely
they are not convex problems
right so that's that's uh that's pretty
much the variation auto encoder
generally the the uh
because we are assuming a constant
variance over here it generally works
out that uh the
encoder loss
works out to be just the squared error
of the squared norm between the two
networks
right so here you you use
x hat minus x
right if you work out the math this part
works out to be just the squared error
and these two the the the encoder does
not have
a direct loss on its own
right so there is no supervision for x's
and and and sig and sigmas
instead the mu and sigma
will
will push these z values to one
particular location and concentration
right because we are sampling z's from
this distribution
right and in case of you you can you can
think of the variational autoencoder to
be exactly equal to the autoencoder to a
simple autoencoder in the case where the
covariances are zero
where we use the
the the the mean itself as the z
whereas in the variational auto encoder
we are outputting two sets of parameters
a mean which will tell you approximately
where z will be
and also a covariance such that we we
sample we are effectively adding some
noise to the z before we take it through
the decoder process
right and it's this it's it's uh it's
motivated through this elbow
maximization uh um elbow maximization
kind of theory but in practice what you
what the way we actually implement this
is to implement it as
a simple
auto encoder except at the z layer
we add some noise in the form of the
epsilons that we sample
right so so that's that's variational
auto encoders and
that uh
pretty much wraps up our
study of unsupervised learning
and in the in the friday lecture we will
be kind of switching gears and and
looking at at evaluation metrics and
other general tips on on how to
implement machine learning projects and
on monday we're going to just start the
review of the full course focusing on
parts that are kind of important for the
uh final exam
right if there are any questions
regarding this you know feel free to
walk up and and i'll be happy to answer
them
you